this space watch this space so so so I
mean if you look at what's happening
here in this school they've done a
really wonderful job and I really thank
the the teachers for what they've done
throughout the class eating their kids
here who've been educated throughout the
whole KB crisis but now what's happened
is more kids are coming back since June
the first and it's um suddenly year six
virtually every pupil is now back and my
message to all parents and all pupils is
ready to follow this and this example
schools are safe to come back to for
early years for reception of year one
the year six of primary a year 10 year
12 in is every now's the time to come
back I get your kids back into into
school and of course on the on the
social distancing measures as I've said
watch this space we will be putting in
further changes as the science allows I
think that's what the public also want
to see they want to see us working with
the reality you know you began by saying
well there are hot spots there are there
are outbreaks in in parts of the north
of the country and yes that's true but
we're moving now from a world that I
think in which we have to impose a huge
one-size-fits-all national lockdown
program to one in which we're able to do
more localized responses so the the JBC
that that today you know announced that
the change in the alert level is working
with our tests and trace operation to
make sure that we can do local whack
Amole that's what we're after
so perhaps an early birthday present for
parents around the country is it your
aspiration that parents of kids of all
ages should be able to go back to school
five days a week in September absolutely
let me be very clear I want a world in
which as far as possible provided we can
make the classroom safe and I think we
can say for I want every child every
pupil every student back in September
and I'm sure we can we can get it done
and you know there are parts of European
friends and even some other countries
haven't got any pupils back at all over
the summer they're waiting until
September we've got quite a few back but
we want them all back in September and I
think as I say we've got to start
thinking of a world in which we are less
apprehensive about this disease yes it's
been a horrible shock for the country
and for the world and I think the
British people have worked incredibly
hard to drive it down but we're starting
to make some some real progress with
tests and trace with treatments for the
disease and I hope that as we go forward
into the autumn people will be much much
more confident five days a week not one
week on one week off half days you want
the whole - I believe I said I'm making
it no bones about it I think that's way
for our country a billion pounds today
and to help keep people to catch up some
teachers scratching their heads about
exactly what's expected of them so let's
talk about parents what can parents
expect that this morning will be used
for every child in primary and secondary
school getting some help well if you
know the funds are broken down so some
of it is for schools to decide you know
exactly what they want to to spend on
what their priority is but the thing I
think that really matters is to get some
more director tuitions and one-to-one
tuition for folks for pupils people who
need remedial help perhaps who really
need help with his aim they've lost time
they've lost time to learn over the last
few months but then also help for for
kids who have promised but who don't
normally get it and this is one of the
things I think we really want to develop
as a government the idea of really
helping schools to give more direct
focus more one-to-one tutorial help but
not
in fact everyone well that would be up
to we don't want to impose that a model
that's too rigid on the schools on the
teachers who doing a fantastic job we
want to give them the tools to give more
help where they think that is
appropriate